Just as my opening sidewall,
I want each one of you,
uh,
to talk about what does progress mean to you in the context of International
Women's Day.
Who wants to start us off?
The only man in
you knew that was coming.
That's okay.
Um,
so burglars in this Palette of colors for progress in the spirit of
international men's Day as you pointed out,
the gender parity excess with a whole lot.
And I'll talk a little bit from a Google perspective as well because I'm the
only Gugler on the panel,
uh,
from,
okay.
We've been doing a lot of work in Taiwan.
The scan,
what does getting parity means?
Something from Google's,
our employees guiding point.
And where do we see,
and it's not just about gender globally,
we've looked at,
um,
minority that doesn't patient and how it started word in India specifically with
agenda Palette.
We've done a lot of sessions as a part of the diversity and inclusion teams in
Hyderabad.
Go understand one,
uh,
what does inclusive behaviors mean and what does equal opportunity look like?
And also setting the tone from our senior leadership to ensure that everybody
is,
uh,
is actually behind some of these.
It's not just saying things as recently as a few weeks or two weeks back,
we did a session a for,
we call it happy days,
which was more about helping educate children,
underprivileged children about menstrual health and how they were not
necessarily aware of what are the things that they need to do.
And it actually helped them open their eyes and we could see it marked shift
from the four day session in terms of how they could,
how they felt comfortable in talking about it,
discussing it.
And also data that we had showed around 30 odd percent of kids drop out of
schools because of,
uh,
of some issues that they might have.
So,
uh,
what that they actually kind of hinted was there's a lot of work that we can do
primarily to help engender Palette.
It is a smaller steps that keep happening,
not just inside Google but outside,
but overall a lot more to it unlocked to be done as as a part of,
as a manager on my team as well.
What are the things that we look at is are we being inclusive in terms of
everybody?
That's that that's when openings come out or when people need to be higher.
How are we making sure that we are looking at a diverse and inclusive way of
hiring,
retaining talent.
So those are few things that we've been doing as we think about logos for the
power.
Uber's,
we're bad at it.
That's,
I might be a little radical,
but I'm not a feminist.
I want to see progress to me is seizing the opportunities which come your way.
I mean you can always say,
you know,
my office didn't give me a promotion.
You know,
I'm not this.
But you have to seize the opportunities and we've gone through a tough life.
But you know,
where we are is because of our push.
So I think it's women have to seize the opportunity.
So there's no point.
You're not saying that I'm not been given,
nobody's going to give you anything.
You don't have to season.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So,
uh,
I come from a family,
see my grandmother was wearing like a,
like an eight inch [inaudible] to me,
like a sitting in a boardroom where I'm the only female in the boardroom.
I think that's progress for me.
And uh,
another thing which I can give a personal example is when I started working and
I come from a manufacturing background and they wouldn't be like female toilets
and I manufacturing units to today,
60% of our employment are women because they're loyal to the company.
They are agreed.
We do solar modules,
which is very close to like stitching and knitting.
So we've taught the people,
the women who are good in stitching and knitting to come and work as factory
workers wear those uniforms and those kinds of women at the grassroot level,
they feel empowered even wearing a uniform and coming to work everyday.
So I think that's progress for me.
Thanks Eli.
I think it's a matter of age or an age factor when I wouldn't be as radical as I
am not a feminist.
But the point is I have never seen myself as a woman with a disadvantage for
them.
So you don't like the House I grew up in my parents,
they,
I have a younger brother and they really did not differentiate between us.
And I've heard that from many people that I was brought up exactly like my
brother.
But when I say this,
I realize how different it is for me is,
uh,
you know,
not only was I allowed to stay as late out as my brother was or not only did I
learn karate because he learned karate,
but he learned Catholic because I learned Kathak he was made to learn piano
because I was learning piano.
It's like the children went to piano class,
the children went to horse riding class.
So I really didn't think that the certain things my mom doesn't cook to date.
I mean she just does not know how to cook.
And I never thought that was a disadvantage.
Right.
So coming from that thing,
I didn't realize that they were two different fields.
One could straddle or they were two different,
uh,
you know,
skill sets that people had based on gender.
I really didn't think of it until I stepped into the world,
but because I came with that much of confidence,
I wouldn't say arrogance into this world.
I didn't ever take it as a personal agenda or assault.
Everyone does it.
Even men,
you know,
code key school enables the new guys.
You know,
it's,
this is not a good word in life.
Shit happens.
But I didn't look at it that way.
So I don't think I'm the pressing for progress,
only pressing for more money.
Give me money.
I want to make a little bit,
give me money,
give me money.
I want to heal child.
I'm only asking for money.
So I guess I've been just pressing for furthering my agenda and life.
But that's about it.
So I,
I don't know what they make good headlines with these lines,
but this is what really my life doesn't matter if you make headlines Lie,
you are leading the line for us.
That sounds good.
Thanks.
I did want to follow up,
uh,
some very interesting themes have already emerged.
Um,
I think the five that we need to seize opportunities,
a chateau glass ceilings,
um,
and also make sure that it's,
uh,
you know,
it's not just women,
it's,
it,
this is leadership lessons for everybody's right.
But I want to revisit that team.
Right.
So,
um,
like you mentioned that I,
uh,
at home,
no one looked at you differently than your brother.
Um,
and I'm pretty much like that as well.
But do you think that that is privileged and there are women who need the
support too to be able to speak up and you know,
shatter glass ceiling,
put support other women,
their management,
but it's not going to give you an envelope with the carpet.
It's about support needed.
Definitely.
And it's not mine.
Maybe coming from whoever their is,
but sometimes what we have seen,
like some of the data that we have looked at is [inaudible] 10 to [inaudible] by
the,
uh,
the pattern might be more the more privileged than others,
but women tend to be a little bit more restrictive in terms of trying to
approach for newer things or trying to be more,
um,
more candid about saying,
okay,
you want this,
they expect things to come to them.
And in those kinds of situations,
no way before this meeting,
it's not like it's everybody here,
but there are some people who have that and then how do you make sure that you
are helping those?
So I don't mean to say that everybody needs,
but at least whenever there's an opening job of board data that I've seen phase
that,
okay,
if you have 60,
50% off the skills that are required by particular,
the whole lot of women would not apply for that particular job.
Why?
Why would it?
Yeah.
Because they don't feel that they have a blue thing that's required to do the
job,
but does not as even with men,
the little hesitant.
I view the issue is much higher torque in the journalism school.
And the boys were the quietest.
The girls were like,
you know,
man,
listen man,
that what should we do?
How do we become journalists?
And in fact they were very quiet.
I'm so,
I think that men also need the push.
No,
it's okay.
We don't want
different,
like you said,
you just can't say this is a woman thing,
a man thing.
I totally agree with you.
Uh,
it would be great to hear from you about how you navigated your careers because
I think that is enough for men and women to learn.
But to when he does point where she said that on the manufacturing floor worn
toilets for women.
So we need to make sure that the system is set up to,
uh,
support folks have both genders,
right.
She can,
I
said that I,
I do agree with him a lot of the main thing that they need to be perfect before
applying,
applying to a job.
But I feel like women need to be brief.
They don't need to be perfect.
They need to be more brief.
They need to be,
they need to have more courage because I think men,
it's like
the Davar Jay like men thing.
They're better than they are.
And women,
even though they're so gorgeous and beautiful and talented,
this,
they still have this,
I'm not good enough ceiling.
So I do resonate with his thought.
But tell me how you all have navigated,
uh,
your careers because,
[inaudible] several different things when he does so many different things that
you're managing.
She'd gone,
this was teaching assignments.
So tell me,
how do you make these choices?
How do you navigate your careers?
You haven't spoken in a long time.
So,
um,
I'm a unique person.
Jd.
I mean other than the fact that it's a good thing to be unique.
The only thing I ever wanted to do ever growing up was to become a lawyer
because in my formative years I did a really terrible book called rage of angels
by Sidney Sheldon and I was,
I think all of 12 at that point.
I know why they were letting me read such books at home,
but I read that and Jennifer Parker,
the protagonist of the book,
made this indelible impression in my mind.
There was no way I wanted to be anything else.
In fact,
last week I was feeling the [inaudible] library and I found a book with someone
had gifted me saying that to our Jennifer Packer says,
all I ever wanted to do was to do law and it was a sin.
I was the most focused kid in school,
I think to know where I was going to the sats,
the window,
two fails.
No GMS is none of that because I knew where I was heading and I did law and it
was damn bad.
Boring.
It was terrible.
I mean,
it was great to study all of that,
but I remember we should have things called moot court where you could be a
lawyer and help people who are underprivileged.
And I got my bottom pinch on day one in the court.
That shattered my entire,
you know,
it my existence.
Then I was wearing a black coat and I'm being fed it up in Bombay High Court,
which was,
and I'm thinking really this is really what I dreamed all my life to be.
So,
and also I realized quickly enough that to be a lawyer in India or anywhere else
in the world I'm sure is that you had to jump onto a moving bag and you know,
if your father was a lawyer,
you came.
It's the same all over.
It's,
you know,
this whole thing of nepotism exists as a society.
It's nothing to do with the just the film world.
And I recognize it.
Earlier when I had got into fashion,
I was working to support myself in one way because my father had the,
we come from a reasonably as a Sakata Whitaker,
he always told us cal supported a degree was [inaudible].
We never took him seriously and laid,
really finished my degree and then he said,
yeah,
do what you want.
And I started working in a designer store and I realized,
you know what,
I like fashion.
So I came back to Heather about and set up a lot,
which is they were not choices.
Like I said,
I can lower that story.
Yeah,
there was,
there were no choices at that point.
Fashion interested me.
I came back to me in those days and talking 93 is when I set up our unsettled
fashion was Shefali in second Dah and to do an agent Bandera hills.
That is exactly how fashionable we were at that point.
So I thought,
you know,
if I get this store and I get all these designers and I'm sure people would like
to buy.
And they did.
And then I got bored with that because there was no competition.
There was nobody opening another store and the Nigga,
she came into my life because he was making headway,
the blues and he contacted a bunch of people who could be good help him and
there was this,
this,
she has a group I belong to called dcs,
which was dramatic cycle had real bad,
but they really should have been called drunken circle in an entire year.
We put up one plate but we met every week and drank ourselves silly to figure
out which played we were going to do.
So you know,
it was a very invigorating and extremely good group that we had.
And when you contacted them they said a church,
I know the phone [inaudible] and or that's how I got to meet
the keyless free McKown camp.
I had Rodman
and otherwise lose happened.
So I'm just really most lucky,
privileged because of the background.
I come from that my colleague fell into my lap,
you know,
every time and genuinely films is my calling and it just,
I did nothing to get it but just show up.
The only thing,
like you said,
I know it sounds very this lofty to say I was brave and all,
but it took opportunities.
But you're also much younger,
right?
You,
you feel it can do so much more when you're younger.
How can say [inaudible] met me,
I was supposed to do a production with him and then he met me and he said,
you know what,
when you audition for a role,
and like I said,
Heather valuable,
could you be a confidence he community?
And again,
sure,
why not?
I auditioned,
I got the role.
So I split the second lead and hydro at Blues,
which I had never been on a film set before,
forget,
you know,
auditioning and stuff like that.
And then while we were rehearsing,
I would tell the actor,
Sakura epitomize Hackerati window.
So near saw that and he said,
well,
would you like to be my assistant director?
And like I keep saying he was desperate and I was clueless what assistant it
gaming stood for and like,
yeah,
sure,
no problem.
So that's how we get the,
and God forbid I ever do anything else in my life.
It just fell into my lap.
So I had no what choices I made other than just saying yes to when people ask me
stuff.
So people offering you take that chance?
I have gone all over the world with that answer,
but I didn't speak for too long,
so I'm going to come back to me.
Uh,
like I said,
I come from a very conservative background.
I think my parents' ambition for me as to like be the trophy,
the trophy,
vive.
And uh,
ever since I was a kid I was uh,
as a rebel,
I would think that something off like my life just can't be like,
you know,
just just like get married and be somebody a showpiece.
Um,
and very early on I started working for other people because I come from a
family business background and I thought that if I joined my own business the
first day,
I mean,
I don't think I'll be taken seriously.
I don't think I would be learning much.
Uh,
so I,
I went,
I like ally is that even though I've traveled a lot,
I went to different cities because I wanted that anonymous or tea or no,
I did not want to come from a background I wanted to learn and I totally
understood that.
Uh,
what did DX to be anonymous in a system.
And when I came back to my family business,
I guess there was more empathy towards my employees,
which I could have never learned if I started,
um,
from a cabin like from my cabin because I went from like a desk to a senior
manager and then a cabin.
I guess that empathy factor came into me very early on.
Um,
but,
uh,
after I came back to my family business,
we started,
uh,
the solar company that,
um,
uh,
that is the cash cow of a group.
And I'm very active in it.
Um,
and we've done a fairly good last two years has been a little tough,
but we've,
we've,
we've had around and stuff like that.
But even then,
I always felt like,
you know,
people would always associate to me to like a family business group.
So to your question,
you know,
like how do you maneuver the things?
It's,
it's,
it's because out of like,
you know,
this,
this thing that,
you know,
I need to prove it to someone.
I don't know if it's to my parents,
to society or to my friends,
but I need to prove it to someone that I'm not just a privilege.
Do you know,
I want to do my own thing.
So I,
I am a startup on tuna.
Like I've done cereal,
uh,
um,
startups.
I started mentoring people right now,
like,
so when you said startup coach,
I work very actively with them,
but that also wasn't enough for me.
So another hat that I wear is like these organizations.
So today I'm a pod of three very active organizations.
One is called the entrepreneurs organization.
It's the world's largest influential organization.
I'm on the southeast Shabbat,
uh,
and Vicky ladies organizations,
few if you would have heard it,
I'm leading and then coming to a person next to you.
And,
uh,
another one is,
it's a very easy to know,
like a Gen International Trade Organization.
It's from the community I come from.
So,
uh,
all this,
like when,
when a person sees my Facebook profile,
like my immediate community or my friends,
they're like,
oh,
you're doing so many things with,
it's actually actually,
because there are many factors to add.
One because you're like job list to this.
You want to know,
like prove it to everyone and,
uh,
two because,
um,
you don't want to be tagged out.
You don't want to be a new one that okay,
this was just like you were born with a silver spoon.
No,
I have my own identity and I think like women tend to try and prove,
uh,
like extra for this.
Like my brother's just in Bahamas enjoying his name.
Yeah.
He doesn't have to prove that much.
And I think even,
uh,
even as an air like,
oh,
you know,
he would be getting the next generation.
Um,
the,
uh,
in terms of the monetary compensation and stuff like that,
it's,
it's kind of taken for granted that it's going to the men in the family.
I'm sure.
I do agree to your point that times are changing and you know,
that is,
uh,
going to be a lot of,
equality in this.
But as of now,
uh,
I still feel like as a,
as in down here a patriarchal society,
there's no doubt about that.
Yeah.
I come from a family of bankers and people were in the garment,
but dyes to sit down and read.
I was not a person like,
you know,
who talk like this is like a very quiet,
nice,
sweet girl.
And uh,
I,
they always wanted to be a writer.
Those days,
you know,
there was no career counseling.
Nobody told us you must do this course.
So I just did English literature and then Ivan Tonto a bit more to Calcutta.
So I joined Sunday.
It's not like I,
I,
I actually didn't do a journalism course.
So I just,
and then even even in college,
I remember my dad writing in Saint Francis,
you know,
we have to give an option.
He put economic center vendor and cut it out in front of the system,
put English.
So my daughter's dorm and my dad said,
what do you,
what do you go to do with English?
Shallow?
You're not,
she'll become a professor,
which I hate or I go,
I would never become a professor.
So I had no idea how I was going to become a writer,
but I just used to love writing essays,
writing stories.
And uh,
what happened,
I joined the in Calcutta,
so this magazine called Sunday,
which was very iconic in those days.
And then I think some dead,
it took off.
And you know,
one,
when I started,
I didn't say that,
you know,
I want to become an editor,
I want to start magazine,
not tea.
It just,
the love of writing,
which I still love.
So it's just that one log we just takes you forward.
Shake hands.
Yeah.
I've asked,
been asked this question a couple of times before,
do we?
I think about it,
it's optionality better than linearity in the sense,
like not messy looking at your career or life as a linear progression,
but more or less taking options and taking risks.
Um,
I come from a middle class family,
their parents being academicians.
So,
uh,
deadly good guy growing up there was Korea,
what's already set for you?
You have to be an engineer or a doctor.
I was not as smart.
So I chose engineering and then it was go to the u s because that's what you'll
do.
So you make a GRE and that night I land up in theU s study their work there.
Then I realized that there are options that I can think of what I want to do and
what I don't want to do.
One of those ways teaching,
like I,
they utilize that back.
Good.
My appearance,
something stuck to me,
but the gene of teaching.
So that kind of was things that I,
I've been doing over an awful late.
And then at some point I was like,
okay,
good.
Done technology down software.
I want to do something else.
I,
uh,
I actually hit a glass ceiling with my colleagues and I figured that I needed to
get the business school to dig.
So I ran to Paterson and got an Mba,
then came back the strategy for some time and then got bored of it.
Then join Google.
I've been at Google for seven,
eight years.
And if I look at my career path,
what I realize is there are two things which kind of our,
um,
uh,
our two lots for me.
One,
I'm a learning and then to,
I mean,
driving impact,
road adding impact.
If I'm not learning or if I'm not making an impact,
I cannot get bored and I wanted to do something else.
So usually it's not like you would continue to learn and you would add impact.
It's not,
those don't happen at the same time,
but either you are learning or whether you are at it black and making an impact
on either of those students up.
Things that I hold true to myself as I think about career and collaboration and
stuff like that.
So it's very interesting that,
uh,
almost all of you said that when you started out,
you weren't sure what you wanted to do.
Um,
and what I've sort of been scribbling as you're talking,
I think that there are certain things that have stood out,
which I think is important for everybody in this room.
So like a lot he said,
show up,
right?
Like when the opportunity arrives,
you have to be present and ready to grab it.
Um,
and also be very clear about what you want.
So I think for many die it was a desire to prove yourself.
[inaudible] it was,
you know,
you wanted to ride and for you it was,
learning and challenging yourself.
Um,
but let's talk about the need for support and allies and mentors as you're
navigating your careers.
So could you share a little bit about,
uh,
you know,
you mentioned a little bit about navigation and your junk and so good on
Hyderabad,
but who are the people who you think,
uh,
we're able to support you as you made some of these choices?
In some cases,
radical choices,
uh,
who stood by our side.
And how important do you think it is to have a mentor?
I don't know what the people actively seek mentors.
It happens at [inaudible] have her learn so much from this person or what day.
But for me the support which is unconditional and was also uh,
you know,
media,
it didn't even cross our minds that they would not support with family.
I mean at any point of time my parents would have put their foot down and said,
yes,
you want rule law.
That was fine.
Then you got into fashion,
we get quiet.
You got married,
we allowed you to,
you got divorced,
you came back,
we let you now you want to go the films.
Absolutely not.
You know,
they hadn't,
I remember when we were doing how,
what Louis and I said,
you know what,
this guy's coming,
he wants to make this movie and he wants to do all this still lake.
Okay.
You know,
another thing,
it was an 18 days into whatever's,
I left my store in the kinder,
the thing of my cousin and I went off to shoot and at one morning in a 5:00 AM
call time I open my bathroom to get out of this.
My grandmother standing over there and I'm like,
daddy went and she's saying it's an English movie.
So I'm like,
yeah,
no,
the keys.
So that the only [inaudible] family was my grandmother when she found out on day
12 was doing an English film.
I'm [inaudible] this child is going.
So I suppose that kind of freedom could be support innovators at the curb at any
point.
We,
we made lots of mistakes.
I mean my,
my journey is filled with mistakes from my obsession through low to the managers
to Maddie.
Do you know the fact that I gave up my store when it was at the height of fits
backup,
Eli was the only store like leads to continuing.
But the thing is I sold my name,
you know,
[inaudible] that's my name.
I want back.
But that's the only thing I have to sell.
The store was on renting the are on consignment so I couldn't sell anything else
but the name.
So you know that the thought of them as mistakes.
And then of course Nagesh came as a director and then he was so clear about
what,
I never met someone with such clarity and he was,
he wasn't unhappy engineer because he was available.
He wasn't a medical because he was [inaudible].
And then of course pause that he just wanted to make movies and he was very
clear about his pub.
And that was such a novelty to me that someone knew what they wanted to do
because I really had no idea what I want to do in present.
Continuous,
not Bostons.
And then as a mentor,
you realize in hindsight how much you've picked up from the people who were
there in your life.
So like my father for instance,
extremely checkered career chartered accountant,
became a fashion designer.
He's responsible for radish,
Canada's guru color and running Umar saffron pants,
colored pants.
That was my father because he was doodling in the,
in Bombay.
And then joined,
you know,
[inaudible] has a father,
they per pack and this after this whole thing.
Then he came to a head the and set up a saccharin industries and a fire
extinguisher industry in Bhutan.
And while he was doodling,
he designed the,
the small little ceasefire unit that we spoke so popular at one time and he saw
that design do the people who made ceasefire and retired at 40 and it was really
embarrassing for us because we are still in school and people would say,
what does your father do?
He's an engineer,
he's a doctor,
he's a builder.
What does your father do?
Not think he's the thing at home.
So it does really embarrassing for us to have fathers like that.
But the point is that was data then I had negate who I remember was it line in
the film called second fellow called Rockford that said,
don't recognize failure than there is no failing.
And I realized that that is the mantra I've used all my life.
But if you don't recognize failure,
then you really don't know you failed.
Right.
So I suppose that became a mentor,
mentee relationship,
but we are not,
we are a director,
producer relationship.
So like I said,
mentor,
I don't know.
I just take whatever I can learn from people and then applied to my life and
pretend I was the one who was part of that.
But uh,
that's it.
Yeah.
What about,
am I answering any question you would ask me?
Yes,
I'd like to,
I'd like to acknowledge my parents still because when you like,
because even I was thinking,
who the hell supported me and who are my mentors?
This unconditional support from the parents is very,
very important.
But of course they thought I won't amount to much because of English literature.
My brothers were all into MBA and brilliant in math.
I'm really bad at math,
so you don't,
but like she said,
they supported water.
I did.
And when I became a writer,
I know I've had a career in society and lots of magazines in Bombay.
They were extremely proud of the whole thing.
And then of course I'd like to acknowledge Dr Andrew Ready because I started a
magazine for them.
So initially whenever the magazine came out,
he would say,
my God at night looks like National Geographic.
And often that he stopped after first two years in calling me regularly via
better than India today.
You know,
he was so proud and then he stopped.
He knew that I could stand on my feet,
just a call.
That's all.
That's the kind of mentor he was.
I think mentorship is the most important thing in life.
Uh,
I felt the lack of it growing up.
And I would Jordan if he'd like,
like,
like somebody stabbing in a desert,
you know?
So,
uh,
and I had you add this on there that if you don't get something in life,
you become the pioneer to fit.
And that's why I feel like,
uh,
right now,
one of my part time Carlos is also life coaching.
And I do that for people.
And I feel that I got into this because actually the lack of it,
but I also believe like every,
uh,
level of your life demands a certain mentor,
a certain skill set or certain advice that you're looking forward.
And it's a little bit Eddie Petty,
but I do believe in the law of attraction and I feel like the more you are pure
game,
the bedroom mentors,
the better people into your life and nothing,
nothing defies the grease of a group.
Like if you have a mentor with the project,
the,
uh,
relationship,
anything like now if I just take in terms of a project,
the project that I can do and now here are my personal growth that can happen in
a year.
Just with the grease of good writing.
It can accelerate to like in a month.
So I am a Ha,
uh,
like a daughter delever off,
the mentor,
mentee relationship.
I think I'm pro mentorship.
Yeah,
it's too late for us.
Port perspective.
Definitely family.
Parents were always there.
And the other equally important or more important in shaping my career.
That's been my wife.
Um,
I've shared this,
but some of the Google ads as well in the past.
Um,
I left my wife and four months,
four month,
four week or it's on,
uh,
in the u s to go to business school in Paris,
all by myself.
And he was there by herself taking care of the baby.
A lot of people were like,
you're a great negotiator.
It's more importantly,
she was empathetic towards what I felt was important for me.
And then he was there.
And second thing,
uh,
when I started Google will be with the New York as well.
Uh,
we had a second doctor,
a second child,
a daughter,
and then my wife was there with both of them.
And then I moved up to start my career in Google.
And second it,
same thing happens now.
Uh,
both of those situations where we at,
he stood behind me and said,
hey,
you want to do this?
Go ahead and do it.
Um,
my colleagues and my bosses make fun of me when they moved back from,
uh,
from the U S for India.
They are like,
are you moving India?
How are you expecting a third one?
It was luck that sneak through.
But yeah,
so she has been there continuously in terms of mentorship.
Uh,
it happens,
right?
It's not like you will find the right mentor.
Having said that,
there are some things that he can spot your one is what attributes or skills
that you don't have that you might want to look for.
The things that you might want to learn from somebody.
It's not something like,
okay,
I'm going to be Bluetooth this clip two and say this is what I want to do with a
hand somewhere to find somebody.
But the idea of continuous learning either from a Google or from a coach or
somebody who is there who can help you navigate that next step is important.
You can find them in various forms and then you need to convince Lou,
look for them the value of a good mentor that's like under state there.
It's a huge,
huge benefit because they can be a sounding board.
Things that you cannot talk to your colleagues who can't up your bosses because
they,
my poor their toy.
Again,
spewing all of that,
they,
these mentors actually help you get the right idea.
We do a lot of user research and we talk to women and they've said that,
uh,
you know,
the reason why I can't pursue a career in technology and pursue a phd and things
like that is because I can tell my mom that I want to be like Sheryl Sandberg,
right?
Because she's this foreigner and it's very easy for my parents to take you far
in Mattel.
I'm an angel died.
So I'm so I think it's important to have these stories from India,
uh,
royal models that we can,
you know,
one that gives,
that make,
that inspire us or fill us with rage to do something like the ones you mentioned
are things that are aspirational women who look like us,
but who dealt with,
uh,
with a lot of adversity and still made it happen.
Um,
that's sort of my kids.
How many can,
I definitely thought both.
Sorry,
you didn't get your name.
Uh,
now,
now when you were talking like every word you said,
the choice of words you use is the exact emotion I could connect to because it
happens to me like,
like lie.
He said,
even after proving yourself dime a dozen,
you're bad instilled out you.
They're like,
no,
by you.
You know,
why,
why should we listen to you?
Or why should we listen to this?
The device gain of advice,
you know,
because like,
like you said,
the conditioning of the society or a,
they have to go back there,
you know,
and,
and I completely resonate with each and every thing,
but what I can see is,
uh,
have you heard of the tyranny of the slight edge?
Like just small daily habits that you do every day.
Did Not,
they need not be important to,
you know,
but then they add up when you just put one marble in a jar,
it doesn't,
does make a difference,
but you keep adding up hundred days.
It'll be,
it'll become like,
it'll be something solid.
So taking the points from both of them,
that perseverance is something,
you know,
that we can't give up on it.
I like the one the best for our life and if it takes for us to,
you know,
convince her parents are,
have those difficult conversations with the people they love the most because we
don't want to hide them,
respect them.
And I think they love us and respect us too.
It's just that they don't know how to,
you know,
kind of,
uh,
have like a marriage of the society and there,
and the new new generation iPods and stuff like that.
So I feel like in a line,
if I would have to see is that if you know the background feeling that they
truly love and care for you,
but they're helpless,
I think they also understand you.
And if he can like,
just have that at all.
If you can just have that in the back of our mind and then go towards our
actionable items.
I know
my daughter wanted to get married.
I said buddy to go live with him.
I mean,
what is this obsession with marriage and budgeting this in all of us to do this,
Johnny and all that.
But she was like saying,
no,
I must get married.
So she,
I think your generation wants to get
not in and which is like your
city is,
it is a CT awesome dot.
Then she wasn't mad at you can die from it
because I thought she didn't know him that enough.
So I said limit and for some time and then before you decide if it's okay,
I feel if you want married,
please do that.
If you want to live with somebody,
a guy or a girl plays Dota.
Basically we need to liberate ourselves.
This is what my point is.
Don't say my dad said this.
Don't say my husband said this.
I mean I've gone from very difficult backgrounds.
I've,
it's not like everything was given to me,
but I just broke all barriers on a single mom brought up two kids and then when
we started a magazine,
you know,
I just went forward.
It was like in house bag because it has,
why should they in House magazine be boring?
So just break the barriers in your mind.
That is what we need to break when everybody says,
my kid,
my mom loves me.
Sorry,
my mom loves his.
Everybody had told me
get a swig.
Remind me,
because
I am in is in this book field,
which we are.
Look under a microscope.
Rejoice if our film flops right.
And it was keep petite.
We come from that kind of a thing.
But if you really do give that much weightage to what everybody thinks,
genuinely,
you will not go one step.
Understand
you don't get as good as the last Friday.
Next Friday,
someone else will get put off by it.
They don't care about you think that they don't give a damn.
I met,
have gone the National Watsi David,
Nice tomorrow.
I'm a history headlines.
They leave.
Nobody cares about you.
We think people
get this idea of what unfolds,
fortunately.
All right.
Uh,
so that's all we have time for.
So it's a great note to Asia,
but I think there's some great lessons to learn.
Thank you so much for sharing your stories.
Seize the opportunity.
Show up.
Um,
you know,
pursue your desires.
Act from a place of empathy.
A realize where your families are coming from.
Uh,
but of course we brave and pursue everything.
Thank you everybody.